Russell thanks for being here so thanks
so much to talk about I've heard so much
about you I wanted to meet you and talk
to you your shirt is so open not in a
bad way
yes don't look at it as a sexual advance
it's merely a sartorial coincidence okay
all right this is an opening of a shirt
not the opening of a sexual opportunity
yes well thanks for telling me cuz then
what it got bad in there
first of all I gotta ask you I notice
hair your obvious reasons I got my own
thing going on your hair is quite
unusual one in all the photographs it
looks quite wild and sometimes insane
how do you get your hair to look like
that well I might ask you the same
question sir for both of our haircuts
look like a challenge to the gods then
they like the Tower of Babel building
upwards yes challenge the God my hair is
held up mostly by willpower
I just concentrate and wish it to be so
low it's I applaud you and your work my
television set like that your hair it
seems that it's crept up like did it
start off like mine has become a bizarre
self parody yeah I thought well well
I'll have hair like this and then it go
out of control and have an addictive
nature for a while I was terribly
involved in the heroin world yes
similarly with hairspray are just more
and more and more yes and now this what
happens is there's no retreating you
know once you go with this worry how do
you go back you know huh you can't
weakness yeah if I came out like with it
flat it would be now people would get
obsessive looks like you're apologizing
just keep going upwards I say thank you
alright if you're annoyed
we could build we could build an ark we
could build an arch of hair Atlantic
between our two countries yes touching
in the mid-atlantic a glorious rainbow
yes we'd make a mockery of Lindbergh's
achievement that's what I want to
accomplish yes okay you are a you're
becoming a big star here you're a
superstar in the United Kingdom a used
you're one of the hottest stars in that
country how do you handle celebrity must
be quite intensive you how do you handle
it well I exploit it for my own free
will it's better than my previous
occupation was which was being what was
called in the United Kingdom being on
the dull welfare yes
you got oddly any money very little
options lots of time which tends to lead
to excessive onanism which is bad for
the eyesight's yes yes yes I know I know
I prefer celebrity to poverty very much
you know given the given the options
having now had a sample of both right
you think you weighed both carefully
poverty and anonymity to fame and
celebrity yes and you're choosing Fame
Coenen in conclusion the sexual
opportunities are far great
I have not found that to be true
have you made a marital commitment to a
lady yes but even before let's talk
about that later why dwell on me your
own career is going so well you
performed for the Queen now in your
country
that's just considered the highest honor
what was it like to perform for the
Queen it's a great deal of pressure
Coenen on accounts of the protocols
before meeting her Majesty the Queen a
flunky will meet you and say when do you
meet her Majesty the Queen you will call
her mom you were called a man at sea
already have forgotten mom as you know
I'm not ma'am is in jam you were bow
from the head not from the waist don't
over bow don't curtsy she won't think
it's cute you must be polite but when
you actually meet at all them words are
ringing in your ears it's brought a
terrible pressure and part of my mind is
always against me look at this haircut
that part of my mind was I'm trying to
think caller ma'am as in Jam not Mama's
you know I'm bow from the head not from
the base a little part miss rig thinking
grab her boobs
you want to do that did you how did she
react to you I'm imagining the police
good thing they're right there with her
at all times but what did she did she
like you do you think do you she seemed
to like me as much as she couldn't could
convey with vague murmurs when people
are very highly bred in my country they
don't like to move their faces I think
if they were to communicate more all the
sexual repression reduce being gold the
Queen would run across your hair under
my hair and end up in Baltimore yeah why
don't wish that on Her Majesty now you
are famous in your country for being
very funny but also you had an ugly
incident with Rod Stewart that he's laid
out at an award show that was
unfortunate and and one of everybody in
your country talking and it was real and
it was awkward and I must ask you about
it what happened it was an award show is
that I made the faux pas I made a social
faux pas I went to the ward to be
acknowledged for my style obviously yes
once there I met Rod Stewart and these
always been a hero of mine obviously
yeah when I approached him and I said oh
hello rod it's a great pleasure to meet
you and he said oh you want to watch
with the womanizing Mae West bit rich
coming from him what's next get your
hair cut yeah I mean it just seemed
right right appropriate to chastise you
for womanizing it's Rod Stewart exactly
right you were Rod Stewart you conducted
yourself in a terribly sexy fashion
okay so George Bush will wish me to be
less bellicose yes well please seems
inappropriate advice so like when like
when I go into the stage I mentioned
that imparting to the assembled crowd
I've been given advice that it seems it
like glass houses you know exactly
always here to tell me precisely yes and
this is what I felt inside of myself and
I communicated it verbally then and this
is where the mistake began I in passing
mentioned that I've been dating his
daughter
I said I'll rod gave mr. advice earlier
you know he said watch with the women
everything that's a bit rich coming from
him mind you I did have a go and his
daughter Oh the word show yes terrible
mistake because also we there had been
no sexual congress between his daughter
and i we've merely been dating as if in
the Edwardian Britain I'd held a parasol
for her very briefly again pregnant
through that there is a way but anyway
it's awesome so please loves you open it
at the right time last stop okay so you
said that but then the best part is you
made that mistake yeah Stuart then gets
up on stage to get an award neee what
happened well I was sat eating dinner at
the award at the function just enjoying
eating the dinner and while I was eating
the dinner if you go this is the real
Justin Timberlake's over there all those
celebrities Sacha Baron Cohen all those
famous people I Karen eat my dinner Rod
Stewart's on the stage receiving his
lifetime achievement award I will
already been acknowledged for my style
as you can see in the food are you
eating taffy what do you mean what is
that it was ridiculous I'm spilling most
of it yes yeah it's now I could tell at
one point I poked myself in the eye it
was very fortunate that my fork was
imaginary I could have lots of digits I
continued the eating yes from the stage
in the unmistakable voice of Rod Stewart
Russell Brand stand up I fought that
kind of really I pinned I'll just carry
on with my imagined Anil
it happens again it happened again this
time more warlike yes more aggressive
yeah you stand out before no this
shouldn't be happening in my life then I
had to stand up that's not fair is that
something happens in nightmares and it
happened in actual reality it spilled
into reality it's only yes you've got
boundaries I thought we had to deal with
the world of dreams we keep away from
them they stay away from us I stood
there and he start to berate me you've
stand here now and told me you didn't
have it all for your daughter so I'm
very sorry Roger - I'm very sorry I
didn't have sex with your daughter I
apologize for inferring that I apologize
it's very bad manners my voice is a
little bit out of order you know here am
i there to receive an award for being a
very stylish man only to be berated by a
man who in his prime wore leopard skin
types and the very basis
oh good lord ladies and gentlemen
Russell will be at the Just for Laughs
festival in Montreal tomorrow through
Saturday and at blender in New York City
Sunday and Monday
Russell funniest person I've talked to
you in a long time
[Applause]